hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm cat does
and we're gonna watch a special video
from epic Rap Battles I think it's what
they're called have you seen them before
yeah like when they take like characters
and then like have them yeah Abraham
Lincoln
yeah and they did one win and a lot of
people have actually been telling me to
watch this one with Rick Grimes versus
Walter White oh so Rick Grimes that's
the walking dead guy right yeah yeah and
then uh Walter White from Breaking Bad
so I want to watch this video you guys
know I love a good rap
I mean Walter way it's gonna win I hope
so post-apocalyptic cop who's got a lot
of issues pop a cap of you and splice
the frame you miss you gonna blue sky
and bigger lies for Skyler henshin
little schemes like a dying MacGyver
family pawn sin by sin where I live it
happens literally Liam flips runs now
who's pancakes you won't forget it I'll
kill zombies are better men than you
before breakfast you don't want to face
off against me I'll stuff you in a
barrel just some big Duty always getting
saved by some supper I'm still in the
middle of the day
that's cool I could watch these all day
dude that's there's a like brilliant
they're amazing that was so funny that
was so good what did you think who did
you think won honestly I thought Rick
Grimes won that one
what yeah I thought you owned that one I
know it's always Walter way it's always
Walter White he's the one who knocks
like who do I prefer then overall Walter
White but I thought Rick had that one
really yeah
even like the end part where he's like
no one's alright coming except for you
yeah that's true meaning maybe Walter
got it yeah it's probably Walter I mean
it is true that well through is just a
terrible person cooking meth and that
Rick Grimes is going around you know
killing zombies yeah it's hard it's
really hard it's it's like Sophie's
Choice same thing same thing yeah I
think these guys are brilliant because
their raps are like badass but they're
hilarious yeah they're rather witty and
clever you know it's it's really good
it's actually like a good rap oh so yeah
those are a ton of fun to watch in like
they get in the mindset of the character
that that is really cool anyway guys
sorry okay I talked over you I'm good it
hurt that hurt you I'm sorry I was too
strong
you're too brittle I'm too pretty if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe right here yeah do it do you
ever notice you talk like kind of I feel
like your mouth doesn't fully open
mine yeah dude my must be like do it I
don't know what I do right now joy wait
I mentioned this earlier but I saw a cat
in a bikini today it was uh he went to
the beach with us it was fun it was
quite epic oh thank you I appreciate
that it's like you always imagined cat
probably has a really good body and then
you see it and you're like whoa thank
you it is better than I thought it would
be okay seriously really sexy it's hard
not to get a boner on the beach when I'm
next to you that simple I want to give
some shoutouts here Eero Ramos he wants
a shout-out so I decided I'm gonna give
him a shout-out today I know I knew a
girl once with the last name Ramos
significantly older than me by like 30
to 40 years she liked me did she really
she did was it was she hide it's like a
hotter woman she was a hot older woman I
would have totally tapped that [ __ ] what
if I got drunk and had sex with that
woman and aro Ramos is my child but damn
if he's a baby that managed to type all
this outlets that's so [ __ ] smart
baby right there my kid is really
intelligent
you should go fighting I should find him
it makes him you know what I mean yeah
[ __ ] hmm parent hey soos Sedano
he said shout-out please on three
different videos well Jesus you deserve
a shout-out because you have done a lot
of good deeds for a lot of people he
didn't more than turn water into wine Oh
party you didn't more than raise one guy
from the dead
you died us Jesus then you got a youtube
account and became one of our number one
subscribers do you imagine if he could
get everyone in heaven to subscribe I
know you like trillions of subscribers
Catholics believe most people go to hell
I know I want to start a comment box to
be amongst people about heaven in hell
yeah that's what I'm looking at this
kinda really heavy yeah I want it I'm
trying to do one of those things where
like there's a whole video
then you mentioned just one thing and
then that's what they're gonna fight it
up so I hope that's what happens right
now oh gosh
anyway Jesus thank you it must be hard
having the name hey sushi how many
people would call you Jesus just like
make fun of you or just like
mispronounce it cuz sometimes maybe it
is Jesus and sometimes it's hey C's I've
never met someone named Jesus you've met
one person named Jesus yeah there's this
Jesus that lives in Hollywood and he
dresses like the Jesus from the Bible so
he's not really immersive that way no he
says that he's really Jesus cuz if you
ask me he's like I am really Jesus and
he says I love you to everyone and so
like I saw him I was like hey Jesus and
you just like I love you and I was like
I love you to Jesus I don't any other
thing his name is really Jesus it is
spirit and nabel's if we get a shout out
we may consider hooking the real rejects
up with some new channel artwork well do
it I want the channel artwork right now
yeah there
here's your shoutout take it a deal's a
deal we shook on it
we a deal okay well there's your
shoutout um what kind of artwork you
gonna do for me huh what are you
reconsidering I like nude portraits of
cat thank you nude portraits okay guys
it would make my it's okay Chyna she
cover-up herself now just rewind the
video and then watch that footage yeah
work off that new picture it's okay I'm
totally good think I I it's it's it's
not a want it's a need need a have Italy
if someone could just post it on
Facebook or something put it on her
Twitter now that would be great you know
it's a new portraits of Ryan on there
and if you can do portraits of me nude
pictures of me that would also be
appreciative than if you do one with Kat
and I in the same one no no no hush your
mouth little woman yes